How do you deal with anger and flared tempers in yourself or your team?
Later on?
We'll go ahead and turn that one over to you.
I got experience with this one life's way more experienced than he
losing your temper.
I've,
I've got a lot of experience with this one.
And I talked about being a direct guy,
be B and a,
a a default of aggressive guy and uh,
and that's good.
There's a lot of good in that.
There's also some bad when you lose your temper,
when you,
you know,
you lose your cool one.
You know,
when you get emotional about things,
react to stuff,
you don't make good decisions.
And so,
you know,
we,
we always taught our guys at the most important quality they could have as a
combat leader is to remain calm and make good decisions under chaos and
pressure.
So,
uh,
that doesn't happen when you lose your temper.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
when I look back on that,
the other thing about it too is when you do lose your temper about stuff and
it's,
um,
I can give you a number of scenarios where it happened,
where if guys had a,
people always think like,
seals are always focused all the time,
you know,
and it's life and death for you guys out there.
When we talk about businesses,
they say that all the time,
like it's life and death for you guys.
You know,
so it's not really life and death for my guys,
but how do I get them to stay focus?
Guess what?
Um,
people lose discipline,
right?
People lose discipline if there's not leaders that are holding those standards
and,
and pushing hard.
And I remember one time in particular,
we were patrolling back to our combat outpost and,
uh,
we've been on a long operation.
It was a foot patrol into a dangerous area.
And,
uh,
we captured a bunch of prisoners and we had,
we had,
uh,
walked him back on foot because they,
there was so many IED threats in that area.
Um,
I think we finally met up with some Bradley Fighting Vehicles,
a smaller tank from the army that came down.
We loaded them up in that and,
and,
uh,
and they,
they took him back from there.
But,
so we're walking back,
uh,
patrolling back and we're almost,
you know,
we're,
we're still a few hundred yards back away from this combat outposts,
but we're in enemy territory.
And I could see that some of the guys are starting to not be as focused,
like looking down their weapons and drop it security in those things.
And,
um,
and I was infuriated by that.
I was totally infuriated by that.
And it was because I knew what was at stake that,
okay,
if we're not disciplined all the way back until we're inside that wire of the,
of the front,
the combat outpost,
we could take fire at any moment.
And if we're not watching,
you know,
at that very second we get shot at,
people might get guilt,
you know,
it decreases our probability of winning that firefight of,
of bringing everybody back.
So,
um,
so it was a big deal.
And,
and,
uh,
but I,
I definitely lost my cool on that when I came back.
I was Jew and it has it like fired up at people and like,
here,
this is why this is important.
And looking back on that now and like that's,
that's not the best way to do that,
right?
The best way to do that is to say,
um,
well I mean forced guys to,
to,
to keep security,
remind them to keep security certainly while,
while it's happening.
Uh,
but getting back and saying,
guys,
here's why we've got to keep security.
I know we're only a couple of yards from combat outpost,
but recognize their enemy fighters out here and they're going to hit us when we
least expect it.
And just because it hasn't happened to us before,
you know,
even though we've done this dozens of times,
does not mean that it won't happen to us the next time.
And we can't,
you know,
this is important.
Think about how you would feel if somebody got killed when you were supposed to
be holding security as they were crossing the street and you are paid attention.
You know,
it's interesting you use that example.
I almost feel that you showing legit anger at that point,
it was a positive thing.
Like you want to make it perfectly clear to everybody and the way you get their
attention because it's not like you lose your temper all the time is by,
you know,
getting angry and people go,
oh,
you know,
he's,
he doesn't lose his temper very often here he is super fired up.
Well,
I don't think it's,
I don't need to probably,
it's not a problem to get angry.
I got really,
really angry.
Okay.
So it's one of those things where it would have been more effective for me to be
stern and not back down from that in the least.
And not treat it lightly in the league.
I'm not saying that at all,
but I think just to Lou to yell and scream and those things,
it just never the best way to get right across.
Right.
That is true.
If you,
if you completely lose it and you're yelling and screaming,
it's,
it's not a good thing even though you're absolutely right.
It was important.
And,
and I,
I wanted that addressed.
It was like,
it just wasn't the best way to address that.
I looking back on it now,
one time in particular to was,
uh,
I can think,
when,
uh,
you wanted to make some changes to our operation.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
I get,
remember we talked about that,
the last part guys are now,
but we,
we,
uh,
I was ready to cancel the op Jocko came in and was like,
well what about this,
you know,
maybe we look at it from this direction.
Why don't you guys make me patrol in on this route and not go across this bridge
where there's a choke point and they might vary ids in the road.
And I was like,
we've been looking at this for hours.
It was like,
now he's changing it two minutes prior like gasoline
and Jocko,
he could've,
he could've lost his cool with me cause I just lost my cool.
And you know,
I've been,
we've been hours at this and I was frustrated.
I was ready to get,
get this op launched and all the paperwork requirements and the levels of
approvals that we need and running around trying to,
you know,
fix all these things and,
and uh,
he actually just looked at me and was like,
we don't need to cancel the up.
It's fine.
It's going to be fine.
And then you,
you actually get asked me some questions like,
does what I'm saying makes sense?
And I wanted to be like,
no,
I can't,
you know,
but it was like,
yes,
I hit totally,
totally makes sense.
And you're like,
okay,
how long is it going to take to change it?
They were like,
I was like,
two minutes.
Like,
well,
we have eight minutes left,
so no problem.
It looks good.
We don't need to cancel the operation.
I was like,
no,
we don't.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
and,
and
like you said,
it's important to maintain your cool.
And the way I do that is by being detached,
talk about it all the time.
And that situation when you've got all fired up at,
I was like,
Eh,
like,
okay.
You know,
latest getting fired up.
And I didn't think lace get fired up because he's immature or cause he's
doesn't,
can't control himself.
I thought to myself,
Hey,
you know what?
He's been working on this all day.
He's,
he's got a lot of pressure on him.
There's a lot of frustration when you're doing these plans and doing all this
paperwork.
I understand where he's coming from.
Let me give him some space,
let them vent a little bit and then let's reapproach this thing.
That's how I'm coming at the situation.
So how you handle it though,
it was perfect because had you blown back up and they want just the natural
human reaction is right.
Then I get Matt were yelling each.
Even though we have ministry close relationship,
we would have cancelled the out.
Yeah,
it would've been a big deal.
It or even if,
even if you ended up saying like,
you know,
so many leaders would do like,
you're going to do it this way and then I'm mad at you and I'm,
I'm all pissed off at you.
You,
you know you came in and Trump knee.
Oh yeah.
By the way.
What happens when something goes wrong on the operation?
And I'm like,
Jocko told us to do this,
do this,
and then you have those frictions.
But the bet,
the best thing that you did in that situation would you actually just smiled and
laughed at me like,
just take it.
Well,
I didn't like that just to make that clear.
I didn't laugh at him like he was a little scary.
I'll just like,
hey man,
you know,
and he knows me and he knows exactly where I was coming from.
Like,
Hey,
I know I know what's going on.
It was the perfect way to deescalate the situation,
which,
which made me deescalate.
Exactly.
And made me realize that yeah,
it makes total sense and then we executed.
It was no problem.
Yep.
That's how you deal with that.
That's how you deal with,
so when someone gets mad at you,
deescalate.
When you feel yourself getting spun up,
detached,
when have you got spun up and lost your cool,
I've said this before on the podcast.
Printers and copy machines,
they don't like me or not.
I don't like them.
And so are we talking straight up office space,
the office space style.
Um,
I don't like,
I don't like printers and copy machines.
They don't ever do what I want them to do.
And so I get,
I get angry at them so I'll lose,
I'll lose my mind a little bit.
Uh,
but no,
I don't,
I don't lose my temper very often.
You know,
it doesn't,
doesn't do me a lot of good at it.
Usually it usually doesn't help the situation,
you know,
it doesn't help you solve the problem.
And,
and my mind is always already,
how do I get this thing solved?
They never helped you solve the problem,
that's for sure.
Nope.
So if you're like me and you lose your cool,
you gotta,
you gotta practice it,
you get to rehearse that.
You got to make sure that you're detaching and uh,
not losing your cool so that you can get the job done when that's,
that's what it's all about.
And the Delta tune commander,
no,
he would go into a little bit of rage from time to time.
And you know,
one day the Delta platoon commander is going to be out of the military and he's
coming to ride on this podcast that he knows that he's fired up.
But,
uh,
you know,
he's my,
my other brother,
and that's going to be a good time,
but you know,
he would get some rage going and I'd have to,
I'd have to back him down a little bit and say,
Bro,
it's me.
They raised to get fired up right now where we're here to win and I'm here to
help you.
And you'd go,
oh,
I know,
but damn
awesome.